for AI progress to slow down it would
need to run out of data compute and
algorithmic efficiency but developments
this week suggest that the field isn't
running out of any of these things let
alone all of them I'm going to give you
a glimpse of what this means in robotics
audio and vision and end with some
practical tips to help you use GPT
Vision as well as comparing it to Bard
and lava but let's start with guia one
from wave which is generating the
synthetic video that you can see now and
no I'm not just bringing it up because
it looks cool the CEO this week said I
believe synthetic training data is the
future for AI because it's safer cheaper
and infinitely scalable that's my point
when synthetic data gets this good we're
not going to run out of data many of you
may not know that gp4 itself was trained
on some synthetic data and if you're
interested do check out my videos on
Orca and F1 to see how much synthetic
data can actually help smaller language
models and the synthetic video data you
just saw came from a scrappy Outsider
training on fewer than 100 Nvidia A1
100s now imagine the kind of synthetic
data that Tesla could come up with with
the equivalent of 300,000 A1 100s and of
course Tesla already has billions of
hours of real world data that compares
to the 4,700 hours that guia one was
trained on now many of you might say
that yes it's crazy that things are
improving this quickly with synthetic
video data and yes it's cool that a
model like this can generate unlimited
data including adversarial examples what
does that mean by the way in this
context well for example people walking
across the road jaywalking in the fog
even Tesla with its billions of hours of
real world data probably only saw that
scenario a limited number of times but
impressive as it is isn't this just for
autonomous driving no not even close
this is also for real world robotics
just 2 days ago we got UNIS s from UC
Berkeley and Google deepmind and MIT and
the University of Alberta you can play
with the demo yourself but it can
simulate a range of things like
unveiling toothpaste picking up the
toothpaste in multiple steps now you
probably don't need me to tell you why
unlimited training data for robotics
might be useful I'll let you watch this
imaginary demo of a robot closing the
bottom drawer and opening it and open
the top
drawer the authors themselves give many
suggestions such as controllable content
Creation in games and movies the point I
was trying to make is that this might be
way more significant than just
controlling cutcenes and generating your
own movie ending as the authors say the
true value of unisim lies in simulating
long episodes to enable optimizing
decisions through search planning or
reinforcement learning you can imagine a
robot planning out a series of actions
and being able to visualize them all
internally it can even visualize human
activities and imagine how a human might
respond to its robotic actions and yes
those shower thoughts or imaginary plans
do pan out when they try in the real
world it learns to do something in
unisim and then is able to do it in real
life and what's crazy is that the
accuracy of all of these simulations
follow these same scaling laws as apply
to large language models in both cases
the authors of guia say the task is
simplified to the prediction of the next
token now limited data was one of the
main things holding back humanoid
robotics so expect more such demos like
this one in the near future this is of
course the famous Tesla bot called
Optimus now this is not to say that it's
coming to a home near you anytime soon
first of all you've got production
capacity second of all you might have
prohibitive costs so that only really
rich people can get something like this
and thirdly we would need more task
specific data real or synthetic I'm
talking data of it folding laundry maybe
walking the dog I'll let you type in the
comments any other ideas we need data
for as Disney showed this week doesn't
mean we can't have robots focused on
entertainment this little robot is not
only incredibly cute but it can
withstand having a carpet pulled from
underneath it it can also be nudged and
not fall over and was mainly 3D printed
this is the kind of robot trained on
real and synthetic data that I can
imagine coming fairly soon now I don't
know if I personally would let it roam
the woods as you can see in this video
cuz I'd be worried that a dog or a bear
maybe if you're living in North America
might just come and rip it up and given
how crazy expensive it's going to be at
first that would be quite the expense
now of course many of my viewers might
be a bit more cynical and thinking who
needs a dumb little robot but what about
one integrated with GPT 4 or let's be
honest by the time this comes GPT 5 or
Gemini wondering if I could dictate to
it to say something specifically what is
your battery level battery level is
currently at 53% what is the voice
coming from it's a Google text to speech
we give the Json to CH GPT and explain
what the structure is and how to read
that Json now CH GPT can answer
questions about that Jason spot how many
inspections in your next mission my next
mission involves 20 inspections now at
the moment the only criticism of this
you might say is that the voice sounds a
little bit synthetic even there total
realism is probably less than a year
away here is my voice after a quick
clone on 11 Labs I think the voices on
these Robo pets will sound a lot more
realistic in the very near future now I
promise I'm almost done with robotics
but there was one comment in my previous
video on RT 2x which said said I'll be
impressed when it can clean a toilet
well just for that person here is a new
video from August of this year from the
company setic this is how well robots
are doing without mass synthetic data
imagine when they can simulate millions
of hotel rooms or even harder your
bedroom and if synthetic data shows us
that data won't be a bottleneck how
about compute that's the raw hardware
needed to perform all of these
computations Nvidia typically drops its
big new data gpus every 2 years so we've
already gone from A1 100s to h100s this
year that will train the next generation
of models like GPT 5 and Claude 3 but
according to this week's exclusive
report in semi analysis that Cadence
will now become yearly that means that
in 2024 next year we will get the b00
series of gpus and the year after 2025
the X100 series that should mean that
new models are faster to train and
cheaper to use now of course all of this
means that AI won't be slowing down even
if companies like open AI can't find
algorithmic efficiencies that's
basically doing more with the same
amount of compute but of course with the
kind of Revenue that they're generating
now this is a report from the
information yesterday companies like
open AI can reinvest in more staff and
generate better efficiency apparently at
the developer conference which is
happening on November 6 open aai plan to
announce improvements to chat PT featur
that speed up the performance of its
language models and a product to lower
the cost of using its AI but I was
particularly intrigued by this from
Reuters the access via API of GPT Vision
they say the company also plans to
unveil new tools such as Vision
capabilities that will enable developers
to build apps with the ability to
analyze images and describe them this
will enable feedback loops like the one
I'm about to demonstrate I asked Dar 3
to create a coffee mod that says let's
think sip by Sip and I got to be honest
I thought what it created was pretty
exceptional it doesn't always do this
well but look at the range of styles and
genres but here's the feedback loop that
I mentioned I took four more outputs
from Dary 3 these weren't quite as good
as the ones you just saw I said
scrutinize the text in these images and
provide a metric for each based on how
closely the characters displayed match
the text let's think sip by siip it then
did extremely well it said the first
image matches perfectly 100% the second
used periods instead of hyphens and it
gave that a score of 95% and even on the
harder third one it said the Sip has
been changed to cka and it gave it a 90%
which was a little generous but the
point is this entire process could be
internal images could be created by
darly internally rated and then only the
best ones put out apparent ly the only
reason they're not doing this now is
because of compute costs but to cut a
long story short I think text generation
in images is about to be a hell of a lot
better next year and it seems like
others agree CCS Insight say that image
generation and voice synthesis is
getting so good that arrests will start
being made as early as next year for
deep fakes we are rapidly climbing up
the other side of the uncanny valley and
I agree with their prediction in fact it
was only 4 days ago that we heard audio
of karma which I can't play here
basically effing and blinding and we
can't even agree if it's fake or not the
evidence strongly suggests that it is
fake but isn't it kind of scary that we
can't 100% tell anymore but anyway I
promised some gp4 Vision tips and some
comparisons with Bard and lava just
yesterday I got access to GPT vision and
I've been playing about with it for
hours since I've noticed for tables it
often makes minor mistakes where it gets
one number wrong in a table that can
cause it to get questions wrong like
this one which country has the highest
percentage of population visiting the
zoo aquarium that would be China
according to this table but it said the
US despite getting the percentage right
48% I even tried to help it out with
visual pointers giving two examples of
successful analysis but even with those
pointers it still got the question about
the zo/ aquarium wrong this time it
picked the third highest Japan at 45 %
final failure I asked it to list the
bottom three countries in terms of the
percentage visiting the science
technology Museum and this time it
skipped over both Japan and South Korea
to list the EU as the one with the third
lowest percentage so what is my tip and
let me know in the comments if any of
you find this helpful well drawing a bit
on fuse shotting and self-consistency I
gave it three different angles of the
same chart but even more crucially than
that perhaps I asked it recreate the
data from the tables I then said check
for any dissimilarities and resolve them
by majority vote the reason I did this
is that I noticed that sometimes it
could output a correct table and still
get the analysis wrong even though it's
simple mathematics so what this was
doing was splitting the task up into two
first it was reducing the chance of
minor errors by giving it three
different angles and second it was
getting it to do the analysis only after
it had already recreated the tables and
look at the difference this time when I
asked it about the bottom three
countries it got it right and then I
asked it again what was it about the zoo
/ aquarium that was the one it got wrong
twice before as you saw this time it
correctly picked out China at 51% if
you're wondering by the way how I got
different versions of the same image it
was by pressing Windows shift and S and
then just highlighting like this anyway
I think that's a cool tip try it out let
me know in the comments if it's at all
helpful but finally let's compare lava
and Bard to GPT Vision on text lava
didn't do as well it wasn't able to
notice that this coffee cup missed out
the b in sip by sip Bard not only
noticed but even came up with an amazing
metric to find the distance between the
two tchs The Prompt and what came out
another difference I found between the
models was when it came to faces I asked
what was the fate of this character San
gp4 successfully said the character is
caman and gave the fate of that
character Bard flat out refused saying
sorry I can't help with images of people
yet while lava was kind of helpful
saying the character in the image is
Gandalf what about some of those table
questions like I was giving GPT 4
earlier well Bard kind of flopped saying
that the answer for the zoo was the us
but it at least got the percentage
correct at 51% lava did less well saying
that the answer was Brazil now maybe
this demo doesn't reflect the full
capabilities of lava because I read the
paper that came with the announcement of
lava 1.5 apparently it got 80% in visual
question answering version 2 that's less
than one of Google's models which I've
talked about before parley 17 billion
but apparently better than GPT 4 so you
guys can let me know if I'm missing
anything about the capabilities of lava
just before I move on though I can't
help but say that I was really impressed
by gp4 analysis of this image I asked
what is poignant and unexpected about
this image and it picked up on the
contrast between the devastating event
that's unfolding and the seemingly calm
demeanor of The Observers it picked up
on almost every detail of the image and
it was a fantastic answer I saw that
yesterday someone had the idea of
putting the Mona Lisa into GPT Vision
asking it to describe the image it then
got Dar 3 to generate an image based on
that description and put it into to a
recursive Loop and this was the result
of that recursive Loop and with the
explosion in synthetic data and compute
I predict the world will get equally
crazy quite soon thank you as ever for
watching to the end and have a wonderful
day